hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are continuing
with the semi-finals of the first match
Fabiano Caruana vs. Hikaru Nakamura and
this is game 3 of their match first two
games ended in a draw and we'll just
have to wait and see what happens here
so the preliminaries are over and now we
are in the knockout stage of the
tournament and for those of you who may
have missed the previous video do join
either made or in a arena or agha matter
so Friday arena or both if you are ready
lower than 17-hundred and also I have
announced the first guest of the argon
mater podcast that starts soon it is
Maxine Varsha holograph so if you have
any questions for Maxine you can use the
email provided in the description below
it's agamotto podcast at gmail.com so
you can ask me ask some questions that I
will ask Maxine so that being said let's
check out what happened in Game three
Fabi with the white pieces opens with E
4 and we have E 5 by Nakamura with
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to
c4 Fabi goes for the Italian game and
Bishop to c5 so the joka piano is on the
board and here Fabi did not go for the
Evans gambit unfortunately he went for
the castles and just continuing in the
main line of the Joko piano we have
Knight to f6 and b3 now so here a lot of
theory throwing around these six we have
c3 h6 rook to e1 all all very standard
joke Oh piano stuff castles buy black
and h3 also not allowing any G for
action for black with a 5 and not Knight
B to d2 preparing Knight to f1 from
where the knight can go to g3 to control
the f5 square with Russia back to b6 not
allowing any any breaks to come with an
attack on the bishop and the white does
the same Buster back to b3 and Bishop to
e6 now nakamora challengers v is bishop
and the disposition was already played
by nakamura with the black pieces
interestingly against Dominguez in the
2019 world rapid championship in Moscow
that ended in a draw but in the game
Bishop the c2 was played however here
father goes for Bishop to a4 which is a
new move so already as a remove 11 we
have a completely new game we have
Knight to be
seven making room for the f5 pawn you
want to open up that F file for the rook
and Knight to f1 continuing development
the knight is now coming to g3 with f5
busting open the center he captures
Bishop captures and now d4 striking
striking in the center we have a capture
Sundy for C capture sandy for n not
Knight back to f6 now that DF pawn is no
longer blocking the the knight is no
longer blocking the F pawn and the
knight can now move well anywhere either
to d5 or to e4 in the future it's just
useful square for the knight so tonight
the g3 now with tempo as it attacks the
bishop bishop to h7 and now shifting
this bishop over to b3 with check we
have King to a trade and now just a
three and here in Knights the e7 by
Nakamura preparing to bring the other
night over to d5 with and also f5 is an
idea you could play Knight to a5 to
trade off this night so first brush up
the e6 keeping an eye on the F v square
by Fabi and now c6 we have Bishop to b2
are developing the dark square Bishop
and now Knight F to d5 grabbing hold of
that d5 square and we have a 4 now we
have night the b4 not that not the B
Foursquare was vacated and the denied is
a very useful there you can you can
attack c2 as the bishop also guards the
C 2 square Knights the d3 will also be
an idea even if you don't have this fork
so far we just decided to eliminate it
Bishop captures and before we have 8
captures and now Queen to b3 are
developing the Queen goes after the pawn
here and here a nakamura defends it with
Bishop to a5 which is which is a rather
odd looking move since what what will
the bishop do there but the Nakamura has
a plan so we have looked at e3 a nice
rock cliffs by Fabi prepares the
double-up rooks on the e-file and now
Knight to g6 by Nakamura we have Bishop
to f5 now now switching the D attack
here if the knight moves you can trade
off the light square bishop but first
the Bishop to g8 picking away our fabi's
Queen we have Queen to c2 now
threatening to just pick up the night
and here Knight the h4
forcing the trade as it attacks the
bishop and the knight Knight captures
nh4 with Queen captures on h4 end now
just Queen to d3 nicely centralizing
also the Queen will be very useful there
in the defense of the third rank and
while still keeping an eye on the bishop
of course
so here Bishop back to b6 and the bishop
is really doing nothing on a five as the
the b4 point is no longer under attack
and here the d4 pawn is under attack as
both of the Queen and the bishop are
attacking it so Fabi has to defend it he
defends it not with rook to d1 but
instead with rook to e4 this kicks away
in a Kimora's queen queen all the way to
f6 and here Fabi has to be careful if
the bishop moves you have Queen captures
an f2 so a Fabi decides that for the
moment first worked the g4 he switches
the rook over to the attack and he will
deal with the f2 pawn later probably
brings rook over to f1 while him while
he defends da for point like this
however now this doesn't really work as
here Nakamura has a winning move so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this idea while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting that the bishop is well already
attacked twice and that you can attack
it again and the bishop cannot really
move so here for those of you that just
want to enjoy the show
it's rook to a5 and now that there's a
triple attack on the bishop and you
can't really you can't really defend it
one more time for example if you go rook
to afford in just g6 is very strong and
you can't move the bishop because you
lose the rook
so what favi played here after rook to
a5 again you can't really move the
bishop it because Queen captures an f2
so far we played Queen Bishop to g6 he
offers the f2 pawn but a Nakamura is not
in a rush he first improves the position
he first plays Bishop to e6
forces Fabi to take another Square for
the rook we have Knight to e4 now now
we're going for an attack against the
Queen but here Nakamura just plays Queen
captures on d4 and okay
Fabi has the trade we have Queen
captures Bishop characters and his rook
is still under attack but
trying to save it with a move like rook
to h4 or something just runs into d5 and
now after you move the knight CDF to
point is once again under attack
so if I be not interested in in saving
the rookie instead was rook to d1 he
wants to grab hold of this bishop but
Nakamura now again just goes with Bishop
captures unbe - and now you grab the
pawn you grab the second point your
rookies on the roof is under attack the
pawn on e4 is under attack and it's just
impossible to keep an eye on all this
rook the g3 by Fabi not just Bishop to
e5 bringing his bishop back to safety
wit without wasting time rook to e3 but
now a bishop to d5 not allowing the d6
pointer to be a target
we have g3 and now just a rook captures
an a4 so here Nakamura is up three pawns
and that's too big of an advantage so
here we have f4 by Fabi but now not
moving the bishop but rather rook to a-1
this force is the trade here we have
worked a d3 defending and here Nakamura
just straight characters captures and
now Bishop the c3 defending the b4 pawn
you don't mind if this captures then you
just get a nice pasty pond so here Fabi
try Knight captures and b6 but now come
over just okay that's a free piece he
played rook to f6 and he of course won
the game and it is unmoved 41 that
Fabiana Khurana resigned the game so I
know what you're thinking like how does
fog blender a piece like this well the
hidden longer a piece it's just that his
position is completely lost and whatever
move he makes loses so it's just one of
those positions he probably already
decided to resign but maybe he thought
maybe I can try and grab a pawn maybe
here he cover plays something else maybe
he blunders maybe something but then he
could just play this and of course it's
game over
yeah that's game 3 of their match in the
semifinals of the Magnus Invitational I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank mr. Govardhan and Matthew McCain a
melding John swore up Chandra and a
corridor up for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous video serum thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational until it finishes so thank
you I will see you soon and heaven
excellent rest of your day and do join
us with the links in the description
below season